dans ce nouveau numéro du numérique pour
tous aujourd'hui on va parler numérique
et innovation responsable et pour se
faire j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
Jean-Noël Barrault ministre délégué
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications et Michael Trabia
Directeur de l'innovation au sein du
groupe Orange avec nos invités nous
tenterons notamment de comprendre la
place de la France et de l'Europe face
au grand enjeux numérique les relations
avec les grands acteurs comme Twitter
mais aussi chat gibity et enfin comment
rendre le numérique durable et
responsable le numérique pour tous
spécial numérique et innovation c'est
parti et c'est tout de suite sur Sud
Radio Sud Radio le pour tous Vanessa
Perez et aujourd'hui dans le numérique
pour tous on va essayer de mieux
comprendre comment mettre en place un
numérique responsable et pour commencer
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir Jean-Noël
Barrault ministre délégué auprès du
ministère de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique chargé la transition numérique
et des télécommunications Jean-Noël nous
sommes ravis de vous avoir sur le
plateau du numérique pour tous alors on
va commencer par votre agenda de janvier
qui a été chargé en déplacement
internationaux vous allez commencer
l'année sur la côte ouest des États-Unis
est plus précisément à Las Vegas où se
déroule chaque année ce que l'on appelle
le Consumer électronique show donc c'est
la grande messe internationale de
l'électronique grand public j'ai envie
de vous demander ce que vous retenez des
grandes tendances 2023 on va dire et
quels sont les secteurs qui ont été mis
à l'honneur durant ce cette grande messe
c'est la France qui a été mise à
l'honneur puisque elle a reçu le Prix de
championne de l'innovation par le ces
parce qu'elle avait la plus grande
délégation de start-up étrangères en
tout cas étrangère aux et parce que
l'essentiel de ces grands constructeurs
automobiles et de ses industriels
étaient présents sur le salon et j'ai pu
constater dans les travées mais dans
toutes les rencontres que j'ai eu
également à quel point la France est
désormais reconnue pour sa nature
profonde avec laquelle elle a renoué ces
dernières années c'est à dire celle
d'une grande nation d'innovation et
d'entrepreneuriat les grandes tendances
les grands secteurs qui étaient mis à
l'honneur cette année sur le salon
beaucoup de discussions autour de
l'automobile mais plus généralement sur
l'innovation pour la première fois un
village tokenisation c'est à dire
consacré aux innovations liées à la
blockchain et au Web 3 qui était
d'ailleurs organisé par un Français avec
un certain nombre d'entreprises
françaises représentées et puis je le
disais 170 startups de la French tech
issus de toutes les régions de France
étaient présentes pour portero les
couleurs de notre pays très bien alors
avant de retourner en Europe vous avez
fait un passage par San Francisco pour
rencontrer notamment Elon Musk
entrepreneur à la tête de Tesla mais
surtout de Twitter j'aimerais vous
demander ce que vous retenez de cet
entretien et notamment de l'engagement
d'Elon musk à respecter certaines règles
européennes de modération sur sa
plateforme Elon Musk c'est d'abord un
grand industriel puisqu'il a conçu avec
ses entreprises des innovations majeures
en matière de mobilité en matière de
spatiale il y a quelques mois il s'est
lancé dans l'aventure des réseaux
sociaux avec un certain nombre de
déconvenues qui nous ont nous puissances
publiques inquiétée puisque Twitter
occupe aujourd'hui une place importante
dans notre débat public et l'important
pour moi c'était de d'aller à la
rencontre d'Elon musk qui avait vu le
président de la République il y a il y a
quelques mois pour qu'il puisse me
confirmer qu'il entend bien se conformer
à des règles européennes qui vont
s'appliquer à partir de 2023 qui ont été
fixés pendant que la France était
présidente de l'Union européenne en 2022
et qui impose aux plateformes de réseaux
sociaux aux grandes plateformes de
réseaux sociaux des obligations
s'agissant du du signalement des
contenus indésirables de leur retrait de
l'interdiction de la publicité pas
cibler sur les mineurs ainsi que la
transparence sur les algorithmes mais
tout ça ça suppose un process de mise en
conformité des plateformes qui prend du
temps et l'important pour moi était de
d'obtenir la confirmation de la part des
lones musk qu'il est bien au travail
pour se conformer ou en tout cas
conformer Twitter à ses obligations ce
qu'il m'a confirmé il va venir même à
Bruxelles pour prolonger cette
discussion absolument dans le processus
processus de conformité il y a des
réunions préparatoires qui s'organisent
dans ce début d'année à Bruxelles et les
équipes de Twitter lorsque nous étions
début janvier à San Francisco nous ont
confirmé qu'elle serait qu'elle serait
présente et que Elon Musk lui-même il
participerait peut-être bon à suivre
mais j'ai envie de vous demander il vous
a fait des révélations sur les prochains
développements qui pourraient concerner
Twitter il nous a dit qu'effectivement
il ne pouvait pas y avoir de confiance
en transparence et cela ça rejoint
effectivement la vision qui est la nôtre
de la manière dont les grands réseaux
sociaux doivent se comporter il nous a
qu'il mettrait prochainement en open
source en algorithme de recommandation
ce qui est une ce qui est une excellente
chose et qu'il était attentif à l'une de
nos préoccupations majeures du président
de la République du gouvernement qui est
celle de la protection des mineurs dans
l'espace numérique et puis par ailleurs
il a aussi évoqué des projets d'un peu
plus long terme qui nous semblent aller
dans le bon sens si effectivement il se
concrétise qui consiste à essayer de
multiplier les occasions sur Twitter de
rencontres entre des cultures entre je
dirais des groupes qui aujourd'hui sont
du fait de l'algorithme replié sur
eux-mêmes et ne communique pas parfois
pour des raisons de différentes
culturelles ou de barrières de la langue
et je trouve que là aussi c'est une
initiative si elle se concrétise qui est
louable parce que les réseaux sociaux
doivent nous permettre de rencontrer
celles et ceux qui sont différents de
nous plutôt que de nous enfermer avec
celles et ceux que nous connaissons déjà
intéressant alors quand vous étiez
toujours sur cette côte ouest vous êtes
passé par San Francisco et là vous en
avez profité pour rencontrer le patron
d'une société qui s'appelle open I qui
est notamment à l'origine d'un d'une
application d'intelligence artificielle
qui fait grand bruit en ce moment qui
s'appelle chat gipiti et qui permet de
générer des contenus automatiquement
donc vous rentrez une question et là on
vous allez avoir toute une dissertation
j'explique ça pour ceux qui ne sont pas
encore familiers de chatity j'ai envie
de vous demander est-ce que ça vous
inquiète cette utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que ça
veut dire que un enfant de de classe de
3e peut rentrer quelques mots clés sa
dissertation est faite il a son
professeur et le tour est joué donc
est-ce que c'est inquiétant cette dérive
ou comment vous la voyez tu as déjà pété
c'est ce qu'on appelle un agent
conversationnel c'est-à-dire un chatbot
c'est ses objets qu'on a pris l'habitude
d'utiliser parfois sur certains sites je
pense en particulier à des sites comme
ceux des de la SNCF où on peut
s'adresser à un logiciel pour obtenir
des réponses à des questions
cette version de de d'agent qu'on va
sectionnel est extrêmement développé est
issus de ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
artificielle générative qui va
s'entraîner sur l'ensemble des données
disponibles sur Internet pour pouvoir
répondre de manière très plausible et
très impressionnante à un certain nombre
de questions et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce service chat GPT qui a été
diffusé ou publié au mois de novembre
dernier a connu une très forte
popularité il y a dans ces nouveaux
outils comme souvent avec la technologie
de très grande promesse mais aussi de
très grandes questions et de très
grandes inquiétudes qui sont soulevées
et face à cela nous agissons tout
d'abord nous investissons avec le plan
France 2030 lancé par le Président de la
République qui a à peu près un an et
demi nous comptons bien rester dans la
course et faire en sorte que la France
soit en capacité de maîtriser voire même
de développer ce type de modèle là ce
type d'agent conversationnel d'ailleurs
en les nourrissant par des contenus
français francophones qui sont liés à
autre culture à nous nous formons nous
formons des ingénieurs nous formons des
juristes nous formons des techniciens de
l'intelligence artificielle avec pour
objectif à l'horizon de la fin du
quinquennat 2027 d'avoir 8000
professionnels experts de l'intelligence
artificielle formée et puis nous
régulons la France a obtenu que dans le
cadre de la discussion autour du
Règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui est un règlement
européen la France a obtenu l'année
dernière que c'est agents
conversationnels comme chat GPT soit
intégrés dans le cadre de régulation
parce que nous avions anticipé que ce
type de modèle arriverait et l'idée est
bien à la fois de faire en sorte qu'en
Europe on puisse développer ce type
d'innovation mais que lorsqu'ils sont
utilisés pour des usages à risque je
pense à la santé je pense au transport
je pense au recrutement où il pourrait
se loger dans ces outils là des des
biais de discrimination et bien que les
concepteurs de ces outils soient
astreint à des obligations de
déclaration de transparence sur les
algorithmes et puis dans les prochains
jours je vais saisir une instance qui a
été créée par le Président de la
République il y a deux ans qui s'appelle
le Comité National pilote pour l'éthique
du numérique et de l'intelligence
artificielle je vais saisir cet instant
pour que la lumière de Tchad pitty de
son utilisation ces dernières semaines
très très généralisé que ce comité
national pilote puisse nous dire si nos
lois et nos règlements aujourd'hui sont
suffisantes pour et bien éviter les
dérives et les usages malveillants de ce
type d'outils ou si au contraire il nous
faut imaginer de nouveaux cadres de
nouveaux garde-fous pour que
l'innovation certes puisse se développer
en français en Europe mais jamais au
détriment de nos concitoyens vous parlez
énormément de protection et notamment
des mineurs c'est un sujet qui vous
tient à cœur concrètement les actions
qui qui que les parents pourront
apprécier on va dire dans quelques mois
a été mise en place la démocratie doit
s'emparer de l'espace numérique nous
avons pris des lois et des et des
règlements démocratiquement pour
protéger nos enfants contre un certain
nombre de de pratiques de bien et de
services que nous leur avons interdit en
tout cas en dessous d'un certain âge
pour lesquels nous avons fixé des
limites d'âge je pense à l'accès au
contenu pornographique je pense à
l'accès aux produits alcoolisés par
exemple on imagine pas un enfant de 12
ans accéder dans la vie quotidienne à
la vente de produits alcoolisés dans un
magasin ou à des contenus
pornographiques or ces limites d'âge là
où elles sont respectées dans notre vie
quotidienne ne sont pas respectées dans
l'espace numérique aujourd'hui c'est à
11 ans en moyenne que nos enfants ont
accès à des images pornographiques et
aujourd'hui pour nos enfants il est très
aisé d'accéder à de la vente d'alcool en
ligne parce que l'âge n'est pas vérifié
et donc leur minorité ou leur majorité
n'est pas vérifiée dans les prochains
jours je présenterai un système fiable
de vérification de l'âge qui est à la
fois
fiable et respectueux de la vie privée
et qui permettra de faire respecter une
bonne fois pour toute c'est loi et ses
règlements et ce travail s'inscrit dans
un chantier plus vaste de protection des
mineurs je constate d'ailleurs que les
parlementaires s'en sont saisis avec des
propositions sur le contrôle parental je
pense au travail de Bruno Studer sur la
protection des enfants face aux écrans
ou encore à la majorité numérique sur
les réseaux sociaux avec une proposition
de loi récemment
déposée par Laurent Marc Angeli 30
secondes pour conclure monsieur le
ministre rendre le numérique plus
responsable sur le plan environnemental
c'est une attente forte des Français
vous y travaillez aussi intensément
absolument la première ministre a lancé
la planification écologique et le
numérique doit y trouver toute sa place
avec à la fois la réduction de son
empreinte carbone qui représente à peu
près deux ou trois pour cent de
empreinte carbone de la France mais qui
est appelé à augmenter pour cela il nous
faut travailler sur la durée de vie des
terminaux c'est à dire des téléphones
des smartphones des ordinateurs et des
tablettes parce que c'est 80% de
l'empreinte carbone du secteur du
numérique qui qui réside dans la
fabrication de ces de ces appareils et
puis il faut aussi évidemment utiliser
toutes les possibilités du numérique
pour faciliter la transition énergétique
et écologique des autres secteurs du
transport de l'industrie de la
construction qui grâce à ces outils
numériques vont pouvoir accélérer
également merci beaucoup Jean-Noël
Barrault pour votre éclairage dans le
numérique pour